To illustrate how joinable threads work, let's take a look
at a very simple program. We first create a thread,
and then we can't be sure what's going to happen
next. Perhaps the main thread will keep control and print
his hello message, or perhaps the created thread will get
control and print his hello message. It's indeterminate. In any
case, however, the main thread is going to execute this
join procedure. It specifies which thread it wants to join and
gives an address where the return value can
be passed. Only when the created thread is
finished will the pthread_join call complete. So we
can be sure that Done will be printed last.